had I'm not afraid of a lot I'm not
afraid of much of anything to be honest
we don't seem like you would be but 2016
scares the hell out of me why's that
because 2016 is ruthless as hell man
like that okay folks you by now you are
to know George Michael died on Christmas
Day on yesterday and the tally of
celebrities who have died in 2016 is
sobering we have a few on your screen
now David Bowie jeanne calment wow man
thank you Muhammad Ali Florence
Henderson from though I mean the Brady
Bunch mom died I mean come on Prince
Prince got me I didn't see Prince coming
whatsoever and I was watching full
disclosure I am I live in political
world too much that I actually need
something his corneas full house so i
was watching fuller house on netflix and
Alan Thicke came on and I'm laughing
watching Alan Thicke next thing you know
he's dead so I'm like 2016 is ruthless
as hell and when you think about all the
celebrities who died I actually think
about those who are still alive who are
riddled with scandal who probably wish
2016 would go ahead and take them yeah
some of these celebrities I didn't have
the the strongest connection to i would
venture to say divo ii prince not
necessarily all i knew uh this guy a
thick alafaya all i knew him from was
those reverse mortgage commercial yeah
yeah i mean i wasn't too negatively
impacted by it yeah yeah those legendary
fighters like Muhammad Ali Kimbo Slice
this year's crazy Kimbo Slice phife dawg
from a tribe called quest I mean you had
so many people told many talented people
who died this year and you know and I am
gonna say a name that I think probably
would be grateful if 2016 would take
them out Bill Cosby probably would be
happy like just to get this over with
cuz he's the celebrities getting ready
to face I don't know what 2017 brings
for him but man 2016 has been ruthless
and the people that has taken away even
over the weekend Carrie Fisher Princess
Leia she had a heart attack and so we're
like okay it's 2016 gonna do her in not
that I'm too concerned about the Queen
and the king
uh the queen of Queen Elizabeth what
everything I don't even know her name
was a name Queen Elizabeth playlist
Queen Elizabeth I don't know what number
she is like what number second the
second she's 90 years old she's old
right but she's like got checked into
the hospital the weekend for heart
conditions and all this kind of stuff so
like 2016 is calling names and taking
numbers and I don't want to talk bad
about it because I'm like we still have
a whole week to go yeah a lot of these
people aren't even in their 70s 80s 90s
prime of their life further at their 50s
or so and and there's also been just
bringing us back to the realm of
politics some political deaths this year
we had Nancy Reagan and yet at the very
beginning of the year Antoine and Scalia
which which caused a big deal in terms
of the ring collection and the other in
court who's going to roll that for the
future so a lot of these deaths had a
lot of far-reaching impact and I'm
thinking about like even the
non-political deaths like I think a lot
of people celebrated the death of
Antonin Scalia well okay hey do you
think but I'm thinking about Anton
Yelchin the young guy who played in Star
Trek the think of the character that
name he played I'm horrible with names
but he was 27 years old and he died
suddenly when a car fell on him he was
changing fixing something on his car the
car lost is is grounding and fell on him
and his friends found later on he's um
it's it's been a really rough year for
for celebrities and we stopped a week to
go so I'm chill out 2016 just pedal
Castro got a point that one of the nail
Castro right Fidel Castro so 2016 just
take a vacation you have a whole week to
chill uh but something tells me we'll
have some more stories to report on
unfortunately hopefully not mine thanks
for watching this video before you watch
the next one remember we're raising
money to expand the david pakman show
big league as well as expand progressive
activism go to david pakman.com slash
donate donations of any size are much
appreciated